deep feelings for you
[Music]
i do envision a life with you together
that hurt that one was rough
i'm like in shock i haven't put it on
yet
are you excited to see me
i'm so excited to see you
i'll just jump right in with
bro
what was going through your mind
it's crazy because watching it back i
had no idea any of that stuff that was
happening i didn't know i was
it was a little hard to watch what was
your initial reaction when you saw how
everything was playing out
i was uh
a little annoyed i was kind of sad um
obviously i i was
a little bit angry
uh but
also i just i look i know that i gave my
all i tried i had to keep trying because
that was the whole process it was like
never give up just trust the process is
what we were told and and i didn't want
to quit on her because there was a
reason that i asked her to marry me and
they kept telling you to trust the
process and obviously you know that
there were a couple of very happy
couples to come out of the first season
were you hoping that you would have this
very similar story yeah absolutely and i
thought that our story would be
inspiring the fact that we were
we had such different beliefs so if we
could kind of show that it can work out
then why not you're just trying to get
through it you know by having fun and
going out and making each other laugh or
helping out each other you're not really
debating
life every single day why you're an
atheist
[Music]
i just
believe science
that is science
but the science doesn't check out it
says who says a lot of people i am
resistant to brainwashing i think you
are brainwashed so you don't believe in
evolution i do not believe in evolution
stop it i do not
so right there
yeah there was nothing in your head that
was like
i don't know man i don't know if it's
gonna work out
totally
those things bothered me in the past
like if that was real life a regular
date i would have closed the book on her
but again i wanted to keep going and try
and move past it i was never going to
try to like change her opinion on that
because that's impossible
so i thought we'll get past this you
know the good outweighs the bad
was there something that made you think
that you guys were
past that that made you wanted
to
get engaged yeah i was i was hoping she
had the same mentality of
let's try and work past this you know
let's let's
let's agree to disagree
move on
otherwise you'll never find anyone that
100 agrees with every little thing but
seeing her reaction you're holding my
mother's engagement ring
oh my god
will you marry me
[Music]
yes
oh my god
what was going through your mind
in that pause where you were waiting for
her answer
i genuinely thought she could say no
we never really talked about
hypothetically like hey if i ask you to
marry me what will you say we never
really had that conversation i didn't
want that i i felt like that if i said
that that would make me sound unsure and
insecure
so i just went in there like you said
full head of steam i was just i i was
like a juggernaut i did not couldn't
stop me so
so
and yes looking back it sounds strange
when i said you're a lot like my mom but
that was kind of like a common topic of
our relationship and it wasn't like
you're like my mom it was like you have
the same qualities you're similar
personalities like that's what i like
and you know it wasn't like yeah you're
you you're you look exactly like me
it sounds bad but you're a dead rigger
for my mom yeah yeah yeah yeah and
what's your reaction watching it and
seeing how
like visibly
conflicted she is about saying yes yeah
i had no idea about
shane being in the back of her mind
so
it makes sense why she
acted like that in the moment but in
that moment i didn't know i thought she
was all in like i was you can see her
weighing
shane and also this sort of like big
chasm in your individual belief
structures that
you know to you
it didn't seem like a big deal but yet
on the show the way it's presented
almost immediately after this
she
is upset in the confessional but then
has to go
feels compelled to go talk to shane i
do have deep feelings for you
i do envision a life with you together i
do have your back and that i would be
loyal to you and faithful to you and
fight for you and be that rock in your
life and that's your wife too
how did you feel watching that the first
time
that hurt that one was rough that was
twisting the knife
because it's almost like she never said
any of those things to me
and
you know i'm not mad at shane
because i know his feelings for natalie
you know he expressed that in the lounge
a lot
but there's always that curiosity
you know putting myself in his shoes
curiosity killed the cat of course he's
going to entertain it and be like hmm
what if i just
said no natalie i'm going with you shane
is there any part in your mind or
were you thinking
you know as you said like why you know
why
did she agree to this was any part of
you that thought
she's saying yes to
progress on the show
yes
yes i was worried about that it did
cross my mind
that maybe she just wanted to get to
mexico and then she could confess her
love to him directly
but
again i wasn't going to quit i didn't
want to quit i didn't want to give up i
had to keep going what happened between
the last conversation you guys had in
the hotel room
and or that we saw and her making the
decision to leave i just feel like we're
both passionate about what we believe in
and we're both not going to change
the way i felt about shane like back in
the pods that's in the back of my head
at the end of the day like
it's not going away how did you feel
watching that the first time
uh
i was pissed honestly
and uh
i mean now that i know that's the reason
i'm even more pissed but
the fact that
she put it past her and then eventually
we do have that nice conversation at
breakfast
uh but now you know like
i don't know what to think was there
more to it than that or
what you what we saw is what happened
what you saw is kind of what happened
um
after she left i didn't see her again
that was it and i i was left like
what is happening
why what is going on here like i was so
taken back she wasn't being forward but
as far as her wanting to not stay in my
room i was happy i'd rather sleep alone
i'm sure you were hoping that she stayed
but were there you know what was your
thought process like as you guys
continued to
i
fly together did you i'm sure you flew
together right you flew together were
you thinking in the back of your mind
this is going great we might actually
have something we might actually have a
really
solid relationship to build a future on
yeah absolutely uh
i know we had a blast after filming you
know after we left and we actually went
home together
uh we had a great time all the way
through
and then we got back
here we
had we went on a day off camera
and that's kind of what restarted it
we were way more comfortable in our own
lives than we just met for dinner
and we said let's continue this why not
let's keep going i remember that i
remember that day vividly
we had so much fun
that we couldn't not give it one more
try have you been texting with the rest
of the cast at all they were like you
know what
that sucks that shayna did that to you
you know we don't really know what went
on
but
they were very nice about it yeah i
don't know what they tell her
but
i haven't talked to her honestly
i uh i checked out twitter have you been
on yeah do you want her so i checked out
twitter on friday when it was trending
and it was immediately like
like this is this season's jessica yeah
i know every post with a picture of us
i'm like this is hilarious you know it
was like the stories are so similar but
i embraced it i'm like yeah that's
you know that's how it went she was
getting it was a slugfest for her though
i felt like it was a lot of
hatred towards her how nervous are you
for the next drop of episodes
i'm excited i tried even harder in those
episodes
i mean i gave it even more when i go to
meet her family
that's a good that'll be a good episode
that's interesting yeah because now i'm
facing the church i go i'm going i'm
literally walking into a house filled
with
people who totally disagree with me
and i have to
explain my why i believe what i believe
that is that's going to be fun
that's that that'll be interesting to
see